i'm praying for everybody who's
contacted it contracted it uh family
members friends i'm sure praying for all
of you because it's uh
whatever i had it sure wasn't fun reba
mcintyre is clarifying her previous
statement that she had tested positive
for cobia 19. speaking in nancy o'dell
on talk shop live the country superstar
revealed she didn't actually contract
the virus despite being told otherwise
yes i did say that i had covey but when
i got tested my antibodies
it came up that i had not had coven wow
i had my antibodies from my vaccine
so i had all the symptoms so i was kind
of probably i did get tested you know
the the test that i had
and it said that i had it but then
um the nurse that came and tested me for
my antibodies said that i probably had
the rsv virus which is just another kind
of respiratory yes it copies all the
symptoms of coven so and this this this
virus is really tricky and so sure it is
it
it affects everybody everybody's
symptoms are some are the same but a lot
are different yeah they sure aren't one
okay doing great now i'm glad it wasn't
the breakthrough case for covid thank
you very much yeah well i'm so happy
that she's feeling so much better now
earlier in august the singer revealed
during a tick tock live stream that she
and her boyfriend actor rex lynn fell
ill from the virus despite being fully
vaccinated while she didn't specify
whether rex also had a false positive
test she did share that the pandemic
brought them closer than ever he takes
care of me makes me laugh and we fell in
love during covet
because you probably were you seeing
each other or you were having to talk we
saw each other well we met in 91 when we
were both in the gambler 5 movie with
kenny rogers and then uh a year ago
january uh i was doing young sheldon and
he's been on young sheldon for
three six years four years he's uh the
principal at the school and so i was
coming in and he he texted me and said
hey while you're in town let's go to
dinner
and so didn't get to that week and i
came back for another project and then
we went out to dinner and uh when we
were saying goodbye i said come see me
and so uh we started talking and texting
um
when kovet struck and so
it was from then until and love during
quarantine totally i love this story
does anybody else remember rex lynn in
the 1993 film cliffhanger just me okay
the fancy singer also opened up about
her close friendship with the one and
only dolly parton telling nancy o'dell
the queen of country is her hero dolly
parton is a
is my hero because how much she gives
back
she's down to earth every time i've been
around her she treats everyone the same
she is a great person for your children
to look up to
and to listen to
she's witty she's funny and you know
when she came to to work on the reba tv
show she was there five days
and she treated everyone equally
was nice to everyone speaks to everyone
you would have never guessed if
you were an alien just walking down to
this planet and and they said who's that
and they said well she's a very famous
person they'd say wow she just acts like
she just is one of the family and that's
what dolly is always one of the family